foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
Zach says uh so fun facts the main actor
from this episode is a dude called
Johnny Alonso and I've talked to him on
Instagram a few times he still looks the
same awesome dude yeah he seemed like
kind of a cool dude I actually likes him
in this episode I don't know why we
didn't do this episode before because
this is actually a really good episode I
keep forgetting like how the actor or
the or the actor hey okay the guy that
plays guys okay yeah quote unquote yeah
which I guess is not really his name but
we'll get into that in a little bit but
uh yeah because I feel like we just
watched it
like a month or two ago and then for
some reason we ended up doing another
episode and I don't know why because I
actually really like this this was a
good episode and it was a pretty good
case it's it kind of struck me as
plausible most of it
kind of like a bad house like you know
but this one actually had some uh
some objects that moved and apparitions
you know it just sounds like something
that could have happened I don't know if
it did wasn't there
but it just kind of sounds plausible but
it's pretty creepy I like this one this
one's kind of like distinctive I guess
because there was like the whole
depression thing and which you didn't
really see in a lot of them
uh Oracle says hey Tommy Jenny hi and
Pookie wherever her fuzzy butt happens
to be she's around here somewhere yeah
she's as soon as I came home from work
and walked in the front door she was
standing right there like
Mama because she was like so sad when I
left this morning she was sitting on my
desk
because I was like before I left for
work she fell asleep on my desk and she
was like and then I was like oh I gotta
go and she's like no yeah she does she
doesn't like me to leave but you know
Zach said uh also there's a most popular
songs from each decade video series
doing the rounds I saw the one for the
70s and I'm kind of embarrassed to say I
think I'm a BG's fan now why is that
embarrassing the Bee Gees are good
I know it's like kind of cheesy and like
you know maybe it's cool to like [__] on
them or whatever but they were actually
like a really good band I remember how
popular they were when I was a little
kid yeah and now that [__] was new
I didn't like them when I was younger
because I was like Ugh but then like I
guess like the older I got like the more
I appreciated that I had no choice but
to like them because my mom was playing
them in the car wherever he [__] went
yeah
along with a bunch of other [__] but
that [__] was so you know was that with
night Night Fever Night Fever yeah that
was the one that I was like yeah there's
all kinds of stuff yeah
Zach said I just never knew they were
brothers or British or white
they know they were white
they're about as white as you can get
yeah and they had that big like yeah
that big poofy hair which actually kind
of like it's so cheesy that it almost
kind of like comes around and is cool
again I thought you know it was just a
music of its time it was good yeah that
was Abba as yeah as it was it was still
good yeah they were boring well yeah but
I mean now that we've had all of this
time to kind of reflect on it it's
easier to appreciate stuff when it's not
constantly like playing you know what I
mean I think you can get more of an
objective yeah uh you know listen to it
Village people were fake Blondie was
good when when that went disco it came
out with Rapture but then all the other
Rock stuff that she had was good it was
all good
gonna became a big Blondie fan over time
yeah there was it was good music the 70s
yeah yeah there was a lot of it there
was a lot of it
um all right so before we get too much
into yeah Zach said I always heard
staying alive and assumed it was a bunch
of black chicks singing
I mean I guess because we grew up with
it so it's like we always knew what yeah
they were yeah so you know so it didn't
I I never had that if you like that [__]
if you like that [__] watch that
Sergeant Pepper's Lonely Heart Club Band
Sergeant Pepper's movie
it was like a rock opera it's like kind
of terrible but also kind of awesome at
the same time starring The Bee Gees the
Bee Gees and Peter Frampton yeah and
Alice Cooper yeah and the BG's doing and
George Burns yeah it's a BG's it's like
a big long music video all right yeah uh
of a beat of a Beatles album
Aerosmith Aerosmith Aerosmith and so is
Alice Cooper
and uh the the Bee Gees are playing the
good guys and they're doing [__]
Beatles covers you know yeah and then uh
the bad guys all do Beatles covers it's
like a rock opera
yeah they pretty much shoehorn all of
the songs from they're not all from the
Sergeant Pepper's albums some of them
are like from other people they kind of
shoehorn it into this plot yeah they
just make a narrative out of all these
oh and Steve Martin is in it I forgot to
try it yeah he plays uh he's he does
Maxwell's Silver Hammer yeah yeah that's
actually like a really good part of that
yeah see it see it high
yeah yeah it helps but it's good music
it's like a big long Beatles tribute
music video Oracle said it's a jukebox
musical yeah yeah I just like for well
for a long time I really liked it
growing up and then when I got older I
realized that everyone else thought it
was terrible and I was like oh well
they've been now talking about but now
I'm just like you know what I don't even
care it aged well it did we watched it
recently and [__] loved it and it's
like not even a guilty pleasure because
I'm not guilty about it we were drinking
and [__] sing along
BG's doing Beatles covers and [__] and
then Alice Cooper doing a Beatles cover
and yeah I think he does he did
um because I think that was the song
that he did in there and like Aerosmith
Aerosmith together
yeah that's right yeah they're all
beetles yeah they had that on one of
their albums but they did that cover
yeah they did it for that movie and uh
George Burns does
um
I think he sings Being for the Benefit
of Mr Kite
yeah and maybe a couple other ones I
can't remember it's been a while since I
found it
uh but yeah so before we get into the
ghost stuff I just wanted to give a
shout out I don't think he's here but I
wanted to give a shout out to Dermot who
sent me a Amazon gift card so I could
rent Barton Fink the Cohen Brothers
movie so thank you very much for that I
haven't seen Barton Fink in a really
long time like I rented it I don't think
I saw in the theater but I rented it a
long time ago like back in the 90s when
it came out and I think I had it on tape
like I pirated it so I watched it a
couple times but I probably haven't seen
it for probably like 20 years so you
know
um all right so let's talk about
hidden Terror
why necessarily hidden Terror I don't
really know like why why is it hidden
because you can't see it
but they didn't but they did see it
though yeah it kept popping out he did
like the title these don't make any
sense to me I was like it's not in it he
saw it it's right there they're randomly
I definitely just gotta put a title on
it they're just like what up it's
terrible it's Terror scary and you can't
see it scary Terror
scary Terror or whatever
yeah I see I kind of feel like this one
they should have leaned into the whole
depression or like unexplained sadness
thing because to me that was like the
most distinctive
part of this episode like what I always
remembered about what she's talking
about is that they seem to be they seem
to be experiencing what we call
independental World oppression right
where it's not
it's not possession it's just something
on the outside [__] with you like
it's watching you it's just kind of like
what that house that me and Eric were in
after we got out of the army you know
which is very different from Mammoth
Mountain which is Poltergeist and it was
just a like oppression
but we never saw anything it never moved
anything just weird presence
a heaviness felt like it was weighing
down on you it felt like it attacked me
one time but there was nothing there
this one I feel like moved some stuff
but yeah this one was a lot of there was
like a lot of objective stuff that
happened and people like several people
did say this that they saw apparitions
and there was like noises and stuff so
there was like some kind of poltergeist
type activity like especially like
noises and things but apparitions was
like the main thing and like
moods yeah like you said kind of like
your bad house that you lived in yeah
um Zach says Johnny who's the actor who
who's in this uh has the most early
2000s hairdo on this show yeah that he
definitely does and believe it or not
he's Still rocking that style today hey
you trademarked that [__] that's right I
mean you know more power to him more
power to him
so poltergeists are not actually Ghosts
no
yeah we've discussed that a lot we've
discussed rspk recurrent spontaneous
psychokinesis
coming from a living person yeah but
it's a subconscious that's our Theory
right well it's not our Theory it's well
yeah I'm just it checks out with what I
observed and and that theory has been
around since the 1960s came out of some
of the parasite ecology departments I
think of UCLA I think is where they came
up with that or at least that's they
kind of made it famous yeah and Tim like
that makes more sense to me than like
people farting around like after they
die you know what I mean
well
haunting ghosts and [__] like that seems
to be another phenomenon
now there it may have some of the
effects like objects being moved that
might be that's a poltergeist-like
effects but it seems to be a different
phenomenon
is a ghost
it's emanating from not a living person
but something that from a dead person
evidently or a person that is currently
located in another dimension
someone like a spirit Realm
or just like another dimension
Crowley says didn't The Beatles break up
yeah dude uh several decades ago
before I was born well was it
yeah they broke up and it became uh John
Lennon went solo and then it and then
well then Paul McCartney Wings yeah yeah
that's right Wings was good too and then
Ringo did some uh yeah did some [__]
well and and George Harrison did solo
[__] so did Michael Nesmith wasn't
Michael no no that's the monkeys that's
the monkey he did some [__] too that's a
completely different bands he did one of
the first video albums it's called
elephant no elephant Parts elephant
parts
then they make that movie called Head
I think I've never seen that when I was
a kid they used to show for some reason
they showed the old 60s show the monkeys
like back on MTV when I was growing up
even though it was several decades old
at that point uh but yeah so this story
right here hidden Terror again which
title doesn't make any sense
so the guy at the center of this who
this actor that we're talking about is
playing
now they're calling him Mike sparanza
I'm assuming that this is not his real
name because he only appears in Shadow
here's the weird thing about this though
is that he has a friend who also you
know went to the house and like
experienced him out of the activity also
and her name is Sarah and she shows up
on the show with her face all and using
her real name presumably so it's like so
I'm like well he couldn't have been that
worried about his hiding his identity
because anybody that knew her and like
knew that they were friends would know
who that was you know what I mean like
the fact that she was just happy to use
her real name and Faison there but he
didn't want to but you know whatever
maybe he just didn't want his face on TV
actually you can't blame him
so I'm assuming that that's not his real
name even though his friend Sarah does
use her real name when she comes on
their leader
so this happened uh in the Autumn of
2005 in Corning New York which is I
think is in Upstate New York it is the
home of CorningWare that's kind of what
it's known for like glass making and
stuff
so Mike
um I guess he's like in
telecommunications or something like
that and he has a girlfriend named quote
unquote Lisa Murray which I'm assuming
is also not her real name either who is
an artist
and they decide they're going to move in
together so they buy a house together
that they said was like a good sized
house but it needed a little bit of
renovation but I guess like nothing too
egregious you know what I'm saying
but they liked it because the house was
big enough for you know because Lisa
worked at home and it's like she could
set up a studio and teach classes and
[__] like that
so about a month later after they you
know buy the house and go through all
that rigmarole uh they move in and kind
of start renovating a little bit now the
first thing that happens that's a little
bit weird
is Mike is kind of like prying off the
the baseboards like in the living room
and they start hearing something like
rattling down the inside of the wall and
they're just like what the [__] is that
like it sounds like it comes like from
way up in the ceiling or whatever
and then this little marble was actually
kind of like a big marble what are they
called the big marbles like when you
play marbles the a marble no I mean
there's a word for it I don't know but I
can't remember what it's called
like if you play marbles they look like
a Pachinko marble to me but yeah so it
comes so it comes all the way like
rattling down it comes out this metal I
guess yeah so yeah it was like a little
the little ball there's just a little
marble we played with kids like a little
cat eye marble yeah yeah Tammy said
Corning is just a few miles over the
Pennsylvania border I'll be damned I
didn't know that I for some reason I
thought it was Upstate but you know what
the hell do I know I've only been in New
York city so I don't know
um but yeah so so this marble comes out
of the wall like this little hole in the
wall
and they were just kind of like
they're like they thought it was a
little bit weird like where the hell did
this come from and how it just kind of
happened to come all the way down the
wall and come out this hole but they
were kind of making joke about he made a
joke about hey it's like a housewaring
present like from the house yeah when I
first saw this episode which is way over
10 years ago it might be 15 something
years ago that scene spooked me because
it reminded me so much of like some of
the Poltergeist would do up in Mountain
and uh it didn't do that but I'm just
saying that's the kind of thing a
poltergeist wouldn't do you could hear
the marble falling down you hear
something falling through the wall and
then bulk popping out of a little hole
in the bottom of the wall that they'd
pulled out you know this thing was the
floorboard or something there wasn't it
yeah they were prying the baby
presumably so they could paint each
other and it came out through that hole
it was a little bitty marble and I was I
creeped out I was like man that's that
sounds like something that a poltergeist
would do and I was which kind of lended
credibility to the story that sounds
like something it's hard to make up some
[__] like that
and the weird thing about it I'm glad
that you said that because in these
episodes sometimes stuff like that
that's kind of like ambiguous and not
like overtly scary is creepier to me
than like really overtly scary like oh
my God I saw a [__] Apparition you
know what I mean I don't know why I just
feel like the ambiguity of it is scarier
to me than like actually seeing a ghost
in your face like big as life yeah I
don't know I'm gonna drop a marble and
there's nothing in a wall really to make
a marble bounce around there might have
been some little boards going this way
but I don't know that's just kind of
weird
yeah so they I mean they thought it was
weird he said that we just kind of like
laughed nervously at each other and
we're just like oh okay that's
interesting
and then it seems like they weren't
there very long before the [__] started
popping off right
so one night not too long after they
move in I guess they're both sleeping
and Mike wakes up he thinks he hears
like footsteps or he was like I was sure
that there was somebody in the house
like that there was somebody downstairs
he's like it sounded exactly like
somebody walking around down in the
house
so he runs downstairs with his pistol
and he's like looking all around and he
can hear more noise like somebody's down
there but there's nobody there
and then he's and then there's like a
jump scare where he kind of like goes to
this door it's like oh [__] oh [__] like
and he opens it and then like a shovel
falls out or something like that and I
was there's a lot of jump scares in this
one
um but yeah she's like there was
absolutely he's like all the doors were
locked all the windows were locked
everything there was no way that anybody
could be in there but it sounded exactly
like somebody was in the house
so a few days after that
Mike uh goes to work and Lisa has her
studio all set up and she's like
starting to paint or whatever
um she says I don't know like she wasn't
on the show so I'm not really sure like
where they got her side of the story
from because you know spoiler alert they
break up at some point
but
um apparently she heard something or
felt a presence or something like the
way they had it set up on the show was
just her like at the easel and then like
she kind of felt something behind and
she was like what the [__] was that or
like it was like creaking or whatever
and then she calls Mike up at work and
she's like um you know she sounded kind
of upset and she was like well I just
wanted to hear your voice um you know I
think something's wrong and apparently
she started feeling this overwhelming
sorrow that she can't explain like she
doesn't know why she's sad she just
feels like she wants to cry or you know
like this overwhelming grief that she's
having
so Mike who's at work is just kind of
like well you know just get out of the
house it's like you know don't sit
around in there and uh you know go get
some fresh air or go do something
now over the next week he said
um her depression gets like way way
worse and she doesn't have any reason
for it
um and he said that she just felt like
horribly horribly sad like just like
someone died like all the time but for
not for no reason
and as the months went by
it got to a point where the depression
got so bad that she couldn't even like
do anything like she couldn't do any of
her work like she didn't even do any
stuff around the house like he would
come home there's a scene where he comes
home and there's like dirty dishes piled
up in the sink and [__] like that and
she's like I know what you're thinking
you know I didn't do a goddamn thing all
day you know she doesn't say goddamn but
you know what I mean
um but yeah so like a sap in her energy
right like she can't like a psychic
family yeah like she's just like laying
there on the couch all day and she can't
like do anything
so she doesn't do any housework or
nothing now Mike does not get mad at her
but um you know he's like well maybe you
should you know go see a doctor or
something like that but she uh takes a
lot of offense at this and gets like
really upset she's like I don't need
help and she gets like really upset
about it
now one night not too long after this
Mike is in front of his computer like in
his office like eating Chinese food or
whatever and he hears like it sounds
like the door creaked or like the door
opened or something like that but he
doesn't see anybody now oh now on the
show they kind of showed like a shadow
go you know how they do when they when
they want to like show you that it's
like oh they said they felt a presence
or whatever but they didn't say he
didn't say he saw anything so they just
had like a little Shadow like running
behind the door or whatever
um but he did say that he kept feeling
when he was in the house
that someone was always there like
watching him
so like it felt like a really oppressive
kind of feeling
and then they then they kind of jumped
to this other scene where you know
they're sleeping
and he said he felt something on the
foot of the bed and then he sat up and
then there were like depressions on the
bed like someone was climbing on the bed
like it was their feet or their hands or
someone was crawling on it but you
couldn't see anybody obviously which you
know that would freak you out a little
bit if that happened
meanwhile Lisa the girlfriend is getting
crabbier and crabbier
and Mike finally asked his I guess up to
this point because you know a few months
have gone by and her depression's
getting really bad and I guess he's just
like working and stuff and I don't think
that they've been communicating with one
another about this haunting business
that's going on
because at this point he finally asks
her
um you know hey when you're in the house
by yourself in the afternoon like do you
feel like somebody's in here watching
you
and she gets mad at him again I think
because she took it I mean she seemed to
take it the wrong way like he was
accusing her of being crazy or maybe you
feel like that but he met he felt like
that and he wanted to know if she felt
like that too but she got like all upset
so he was just like all right never mind
you know what I mean and Mike said that
it wasn't just her like he felt like he
was getting angry for no reason like he
would just have like fits of rage and
stuff like that and not be able to
explain like what he was mad about
exactly that fits a description of
what's called oppression yeah
I guess it's kind of a weird phenomenon
or a real phenomenon in Mammoth Mountain
the Poltergeist event I was involved in
as a kid
Wesley seemed to slightly be under the
influence of [__] oppression but
either that or he just that's just how
he showed fear
because he really couldn't understand
what was happening him being deaf
and slightly autistic too it was weird
yeah you said that he seemed like he was
sleeping a lot leaving a lot and look at
he looked Dead when he was asleep you
know he looked real almost catatonic and
then um
he was real tense
um
when we go up to get stairs together had
the feeling that there was something
behind us we'd run from it and get to
the top stairs and turn around and look
see what it was chasing us there'd be
nothing there now he felt it too
every time we went up those stairs
from the
first floor to the second floor we
couldn't just walk up it we had to like
slowly just start running like there was
something chasing us
we'd look down there'd be nothing there
it's weird yeah that's pretty creepy
yeah
and he'd like laugh a little bit like
you felt it too you know I could tell
you know
his sign language wasn't even that good
you know what I mean it was real vague
his language skills weren't that good
but he he was like you felt that too I
could
read it in his body language in his eyes
I said yeah there's nothing there
so I think he was I think he was being
affected by it he was trying to block it
out
as an adult he said no that didn't
happen and red was like is his his
stepdad was like no that did happen and
that scared him bad he didn't want to
talk about it anymore
yeah he was trying to deny that that
happened
although like I said later on he did
kind of like in the book he says right
he did write to me right
or he at least told Lois like what yeah
and what he wrote I asked him what I
asked him about it he goes he said it
was a bad place he said it was a place
where there was an he basically said it
was where some kind of evil magician had
a had a great career that's what he said
that's what he wrote to me that's just
that's weird that he said that yeah I
know that was his imagination but I know
what he's talking about it felt like
something bad happened there
the I don't think it was location based
it was just an illusion because wherever
I went it's where it was yeah it just
followed you because like I said I think
it was you doing it
yeah icon it's a fake ghost
made by psychic abilities
telekinesis
So speaking of uh Poltergeist stuff one
thing that Mike said happened all the
time
was that he was in the habit of you know
getting the mail and kind of like
leaving it on the um like the table like
next to the front door and he saw
whenever he came home it was always like
scattered all over the floor
and he's like that can't be happening
like that all the time and Lisa didn't
do it and it's just like so he couldn't
figure it out so he's like he would
always come home and the mail was just
like scattered all over the place and he
couldn't figure out why I was doing that
so because the
um the mood at home is not good I mean
Lisa is really depressed and he doesn't
really like being in the house either
because he feels like he's being watched
so it's like a lot of tension and stuff
so Mike starts staying at work like
longer and longer
so he doesn't have to hang out in the
house all that long
then there's a scene where Lisa it's and
I'm assuming it's afternoon or evening
and she's in the house by herself and
she's like in the bathroom like she just
gets out of the shower and then she's
looks in the mirror and she sees like a
little Ghost Boy
like in the shower like peeking around
the shower curtain which you know I
guess you just saw it for a second like
I said she wasn't the real woman was not
on the show so I'm presuming that we're
second hand this is just like a
secondhand account maybe she told Mike
at the time and like he's relaying like
what she saw but apparently it was like
a little boy that she saw in the tub
like in the shower
so um as I mentioned Mike is starting to
dread coming home it's like he said the
closer he got to the house like the more
he would tense up and you know
inevitably every time he would come in
the house like the male would be all
over the floor and he's happy to keep
picking it up and piling it back on
there
so one particular evening he comes home
and Lisa is sleeping on the couch and
again she's been just like sleeping
there all day and hasn't done anything
now she tries to he's trying to like
talk to her about this haunting he's
like we need to talk about like what's
going on in this house because it's
affecting him as well and I guess her
coping strategy was just like pretending
that there was absolutely nothing going
on because she got would get really
angry like anytime that you brought it
up and was just kind of in denial about
it I guess I think that's part of the
oppression maybe it was yeah she was in
denial of what was happening to her
but yeah so he basically says well you
need to get out of the house you know
for your own well-being and then she
gets mad again it's like oh what do you
want me to do just like go out and have
coffee with my girlfriends and all this
other kind of [__] just so I can be
happy for you and blah blah and he's
like no I mean you need to get out you
need to move out of the house like
basically like he wasn't mean about it
like at least on the show he wasn't like
get the hell out of here but um you know
he was basically like and he said that
he felt really bad about it but he's
like man she was like not having a good
time in that house and he was just
worried about her and like he was
starting to worry about her and he's
like I just think it would be better
like if you were not here like if you
got out of here because this house is
obviously sucking all your energy out or
whatever
um but you know he did think it was best
for her even though he said he was
really upset about it now at this point
he pretty much admits to himself okay
well the house is haunted clearly
so he starts putting on his webcam
during the day because he's like I got
kind of he's like it was bad but he's
like I got kind of curious about it so
he would leave his webcam like running
like recording during the day to like to
see if he could catch anything going on
because he was sure that there was
something in the house
he also starts experimenting with the
male he said I thought maybe you know
he's like this is stupid but um he's
like maybe like some neighborhood kids
were breaking it and like scattering
them at like for whatever reason he's
like I couldn't really think of anything
else other than paranormal [__] so he's
like so I thought to uh you know kind of
preclude that that possibility he would
leave like a 20 bill or something like
that like on top of the mail he's like
so if somebody was breaking in and like
doing that then they would obviously
take the money but the money was never
taken
so he's like well obviously something
else is going on then now he also like I
said records the stuff on the webcam but
he never caught anything on the webcam
which actually to me and I was thinking
this while I was watching the episode I
was like that makes it seem a little bit
more believable to me because you would
think that they would have lied and said
it's like oh my God we got like this
door open or something like that but
he's like I didn't see [__] on the
webcam like he didn't get anything like
it was just nothing unusual on there at
all even though he recorded like all day
long just the whole tone of this episode
in the case
made me he kind of gave me the feeling
of credibility to it and authenticity
just like I said it wasn't there I can't
vouch for it but it just it has a very
authentic feel to it
based on my experience with what they
call the Paranormal
yeah it would be the next announcer of
this [__]
and you know I've had some weird [__]
happen to me [__] for my whole life
you know dreaming true uh [__] having
premonitions out of body experiences
[__] near-death experiences
Poltergeist I guess this was Haunting at
the bad house very mild haunting though
weird sleep disturbances you know where
I've
dreamed I saw somebody in a dream and
then said something to him in the dream
and then afterwards that person [__]
remembered the same dream and I said the
same thing so I guess I'll call it dream
invasion you guys were meeting up in the
dream world yeah
yeah weird stuff like that
so and I think I think weird phenomenal
like that happens with a lot of people
I'm not the only one yeah I've heard
other people talking about that yeah it
was just something about me I guess
getting me and my upbringing
all right um it was happening to me
especially when I was young out of
a pretty regular rate
it was pretty regular
and I just accepted it for what it was I
said yeah people can do this
you know but this one kind of this case
kind of
feels authentic based upon my personal
experience
well and this was another one that I
liked because they didn't call in the
church there's no exorcism [__]
there's none of that okay yeah it's just
people trying to deal with it on their
own which that's what would happen to us
we just try to do it we're afraid to
call people that they think us that we
were crazy we figured man if we call the
cops the cops will show up and all this
phenomena will stop and we'll look crazy
as [__] yeah because that's what because
it was a prankster you know you just had
to deal with it yourself
but yeah I tend to I tend to prefer the
episodes where they don't get all like
religiously where they're just kind of
like well we're dealing with this and
then we'll maybe call the paranormal
investigators yeah and like sometimes
when they bring in the psychics it gets
a little bit cheesy then too but this
woman was actually not too bad the case
always goes sideways when they bring in
a damn [__] psychic
you notice that whenever they bring in a
psychic man all of a sudden
a narrative starts forming and it's
always hokey
although this one didn't really have
that they did bring in a sensitive but
they didn't try to like impose a story
onto the [__] they didn't really try so
I appreciate it yeah but they used it is
oh a long time ago there was a murder in
this house oh come on
I mean it'd be one thing if there was uh
you know actual evidence of that
happening but there never seems to be no
so it's just kind of like you can just
come in there and be like yeah this
happened like 200 years ago and oh
conveniently like all the records were
lost in a fire or some [__] yeah you
know what I mean so but I do like that
this one you know they said they got
some evidence and stuff but they didn't
try to like impose a narrative on it
which was nice
so uh so yeah so he doesn't see anything
on the webcam now later on
he's sleeping again and he's woken up by
he said that he heard two arguing voices
I'm assuming like in his room
and he said that you know he couldn't
make out everything they were saying but
he's like they sounded like they were
arguing about him which he said that
scared the [__] out of me you know what
I mean
um wish it would if you woke up and
heard two disembodied voices arguing
about what they were going to do with
you yeah and that's yeah he said he
couldn't really tell what they were
saying he just thought they were talking
about him yeah which that also kind of
sounds plausible you know what I mean
haven't seen paranormal [__]
I did hear a voice but I couldn't make
sense out of it just sounded like
gargling water and
suddenly was backwards scared the [__]
out of me I ran from it that was later
on the first time you told me that story
and you did the sound yeah all the hair
stood up
if I heard that just like coming out of
the [__] wall or whatever I would
probably [__] I jumped up out of the
damn cot because I was you know they
gave me a fold out cut I was staying at
Lois's house jumped out of the fold out
caught [__] grabbed the sleeping bag
because I was in a sleeping bag and
[__] took out they were sleeping bags
nope the [__] out of there because and I
ran into Lois and Red's room threw that
[__] on the [__] foot
at the foot of their bed and climbed in
there and said what's wrong it says that
thing's trying to talk at that I I'm not
I don't want to hear that thing talk
yeah it's like I'm not interested in
anything that is this thing was [__]
trying to talk
and it was loud as my voice is right now
I wonder what it was I started silently
and it went up got louder and louder
it's like
[Music]
it's like that sunlight was underwater
Bubbles and [__] oh man it was [__]
weird yeah that's creepy yeah
I left Wesley in there he was deaf he
couldn't hear it
he'll be fine he
had been throwing clothes on me the
night before
when I was in that sleeping bag
out of the dresser that was [__]
weird man my [__] hair still stands
up thinking about some of the how strong
it got and the [__] that it did
Oracle said it's spookier without the
Hokey I agree I think stuff is scarier
when there's like no there's not really
any context you know what I mean when do
you try to like
I I think that maybe people try to
impose a narrative on it like to make
themselves feel better about it because
you're classifying it you're explaining
it you're to some degree but I don't
know to me like it's creepier when you
don't know anything about it when it's
just kind of random
um pour one out for Wesley poor dude
yeah he'd be all right he was all right
he's all right he didn't know he's fine
um it wasn't messing with him
yeah it was mostly just the only thing
it did to him and during that episode
during during that those few days
is that he was autistic he did funny
[__] okay he'd stack up [__] mad he
had you know those little Signet books
they're like a little
small novels well you could get Mad
Magazine like that yeah hundreds of
those and he'd have them stacked up all
in order because he had numbers and [__]
and he had a badminton racket [__]
tax to the [__] wall like it was a
decoration I don't think he really knew
what a badminton racket was
and Lois was watching him in bed because
[__] was moving and he was asleep and
[__] I just walked out of there
about five minutes before I was in the
living room and Lois looked I saw Lois
and she looked at him and while he was
in bed and he was all right she was
standing in a doorway then she looked
back in the living room with me and then
a few seconds later she'd look back in
there again and she startled she went
look at that thing and I ran oh man near
them caught my choke myself I ran over
there to see what it was she was looking
at it had taken the badminton bracket
off the wall and put it in a [__]
jacket and a pair of pants and I put a
baseball cap on it and made a human form
next to Wesley in bed with him
like a second in a second in my [__]
hair I had hair back then
I was like no [__] way look at that
look at that thing and Lois was like oh
hell no no no no no and she wanted she
picked all that [__] up and threw it in
the [__] corner or something I don't
remember what she's like no that didn't
happen it was that kind of thing yeah
well yeah that's what you did yeah it
was it I nope the [__] out it made a
human form and put a baseball cap on the
badminton racket like I was wearing a
hat
in it and the the you know the handle of
it it was down inside the jacket
you know and then the pants were inside
the base of the jacket it was laid out
perfectly and it did it like in a second
couple seconds that's crazy yeah
so you could do [__] amazing things
in a short period of time I don't know
how it did it and he was snoring the
whole time
there's no way no way he could have done
it
Oracle said my big ghost experience was
hearing a ghost play the pipe organ in a
fully lit room not a full piece just a
quick riff like a warm-up it freaked me
out oh wow yes my friends just nodded
and said yeah that's Dr Louise Wright
reportedly she also enhances your
performance if she thinks you need it
which is a very teacher thing to do
she gets your dick hard
or playing the organ rather well yeah
she can play on the organ
like the spiritual Viagra
Spirit go in there and [__] stiffen
that [__] up in a heartbeat oh my God I
was like that scene from Ghostbusters
yeah where Rey has that ghost like unzip
his pants yeah do you remember that yeah
Zach said you know the only thing
missing from Johnny's look in this show
is if he had blonde highlights on the
tips of his hair yeah he did not have it
he had that kind of like Shaggy 2000s
look but yeah no no blonde tips uh sadly
and no and he didn't have a goatee wait
did he he'd have a goatee did it like a
soul patch or something because I'm
those were very big back then
um but yeah so he hears these two
arguing voices like I said
and he thought they were arguing about
him so basically like yells what do you
want at them and then you know but then
the voices stop suddenly
so at this point uh probably
understandably he starts like sleeping
at his office they show him like kind of
curled up on this little couch in the
break room or whatever
and then a co-worker a friend of his
like comes in and brings him a cup of
coffee or whatever like hey man I don't
know if he like explained like why he
was leaving at the office or whatever
and he tells the guy that you know the
guy's like yeah you are right or
everything he's like you know um can I
tell you something about my house he's
like yeah sure he's like I'm pretty sure
it's haunted and at this point the guy's
just like yeah right then he gets up and
leaves I'm like gee thanks bud super
supportive
so he's like yeah I'm not gonna tell
anybody about this [__] anymore
um but also on the other hand he kind of
felt like he wanted to move but then he
was like well I don't really want to be
chased out of my own house either and he
was still kind of curious about it
so one evening he's like sitting on the
couch watching TV I don't know if he was
watching cartoons or if he just like was
watching something else and he fell
asleep and then cartoons subsequently
came on but there were cartoons on
he was sleeping on the couch
so he wakes up and he's like oh guess I
gotta go to bed he turns off the TV
and he said that he saw for a second a
little boy sitting in front of the TV
and he said that the little boy turned
around and looked at him like Hey I was
watching that yeah like the little ghost
boy was watching the cartoons
and he was kind of like freaked out so
he turned the TV back on like for the
Little Ghost Boy to watch it
and uh so he's like yeah I'm just gonna
go in the other room she's going out of
the room and then he's like later on the
TV turned itself off by itself
yeah it's also kind of creepy that is
very creepy I mean it's not like
something that you would actually see in
a
in a haunting yeah yeah it wasn't some
kind of a
ghost rattling chains or you know what I
mean or ghost doing something that was
epic it was just a little kid watching
TV he's like I was watching just real
mundane you know hard to make up
something like that if they did make
that up that was brilliant
yeah like I said it's always scarier and
more believable if it's nothing if it's
if it doesn't have a narrative and if
it's kind of like more like just regular
[__] [__] yeah like I don't the ones
that are just like demons going like
like that's not scary to me at all I
mean yeah if it happened in real life if
I had a demon dude yeah it'd probably be
scary but I'm just saying like in a
movie and something like that it's not
scary because it's just it's too much
it's over the top
so uh so yeah
now again he's thinking well maybe I
will move because this is getting a
little out of hand
so he's hanging out with his friend
Sarah now the real Sarah was on the show
like I said and she apparently used her
real name and she you know wasn't in
Shadow
so they're hanging out having coffee or
whatever and she said yeah we've been
friends a really long time
now he doesn't tell Sarah about the
haunting at first but he does tell her
you know I'm thinking about selling the
house and she's like what are you
talking about like you just bought it
like you just moved in there and he's
like well you know it's like it needs a
lot of work like before I sell it and I
can't really afford to do all the
renovations or I don't really have the
time to do the renovations because I
have to work so much blah blah
so Sarah then volunteers she's like well
you know I'm off on Mondays it's like if
you want me to come over and like you
know help you paint or whatever she's
like I can totally do that
so he's like okay well that would be
really cool but he does not tell her
that the house is haunted and I think
that he implied that he did that
deliberately because he wanted to see if
this is kind of shitty but um he wanted
to see if something would happen to her
so he knew that he wasn't crazy like he
wasn't just imagining it you know what I
mean so he wanted to see if like the
same user is the control right wasn't
going to tell her either that's what I'm
saying like she was a little bit pissed
about we'll get into that a little bit
so Sarah comes to the house on Monday
and he goes off to work
and she starts painting she's got all
the latter and [__] laid out
but she's not really there that long she
literally goes up on the ladder and
she's like one stroke of paint or
whatever and then there's like
um kind of like a shadow jump scare like
she's like a shadow out of the corner of
her eye or something like that and then
she starts feeling apparently the same
overwhelming and unexplained sadness
that Lisa had felt before she's just
like I just felt suddenly like I like
somebody had died and like if somebody
had told me that a loved one had died
and like I just wanted to cry and I
didn't know why
so
um Mike calls to ask like how she's
doing and she sounds really bad but
she's just like oh I guess I just have a
cold or something like that
but she she's like then she just like
started crying like the rest of the day
and then she said like 20 like for 20
minutes she just kind of like stood
there like she couldn't move again like
oppression like we were talking about
and then she hears she said she heard
very distinctly like rustling on the
drop cloth because they like that
plastic all that plastic drop cloth like
around because they were painting
we're out of vodka
yeah that's fine like I said I gotta
work tomorrow I don't need to drink a
lot
but yeah so she heard rustling on the
drop cloth like someone was walking on
it
and so she goes to investigate and she
sees kind of like a silhouette it looked
like in the bathroom kind of thing and
there was like plastic hanging
everywhere and she thought there was
somebody like in the tub but then she
pulled in it was just like a coat or
whatever but then she said she heard
really loud walking on the plastic she
said it was very clearly somebody
walking very loudly across this plastic
drop cloth and she was like yeah no I'm
out of here so she runs out of the house
she said that she felt very strongly
that something very bad was gonna happen
if she stayed in there so she just ran
outside
so after this they meet back up at the
coffee shop and Sarah tells Mike what
happened at the house
and Mike is freaked out because the
feeling of overwhelming sadness that she
described he's like that's just like
what Lisa said like his ex-girlfriend
and Mike finally admits uh yeah I I've
heard and seen all kinds of [__] too in
the house uh you know and Sarah was like
well
probably should have told me like before
you let me hang out in there all day by
myself so thanks bro but um you know she
wasn't that mad about it but I guess it
you know I'd be kind of mad about her
too but he was like well you know I I
hate to do that to you but he's like I
had to know like if it was real and I
guess it is because you felt the same
way and I didn't tell you anything
so now Sarah is obviously kind of scared
about this but she is also kind of
interested so she's going to help him
like investigate so she's like we need
to call like some paranormal
investigators or some [__] some Ghost
Hunters
so they call up this team
I think they were called Central New
York Ghost Hunters oh well uh why did I
think it was Upstate New York because it
says right there Central New York jeez
I'm stupid I wasn't paying attention
Okay so I think it was called Central
New York centers and the main person was
Stacy Jones I think was her name
and then you had another guy named Kyle
who's like the videotaping guy and then
um you have the psychic sensitive person
his name was Regina she was also on the
show like for real actually most of the
team was on there now I'm thinking about
it uh and then they have another guy
named James who's like the EVP and photo
guy
now they said as soon as the team got
there they heard very distinctive
banging sounds upstairs and there was no
one up there and they said this was
actually kind of a big deal for them
because usually they're like you know
when we get there it takes like a few
days for us to even see anything if we
do see anything so the fact that as soon
as we walked in the door like phenomena
started that was like kind of a big
thing
so they go in the master bedroom and set
up to do EVPs
so they asked Sarah to go even though
she's kind of [__] in her pants she's
like I don't really want to do this but
okay but um so they have her and Regina
like go up there in the in the master
bedroom and Sarah has like the little
tape recorder thing like around her neck
or whatever
so they go in there and Mike ends up
getting called into work and he's like
well it might be better anyway because
you know I feel like a lot of stuff
doesn't happen like when I'm here like I
you know it seems more responsive to
just when women are alone in the house
so he's like maybe you'll get more
phenomenal if I'm not here
so he left uh so Sarah and the team are
staying in the house
so they start asking all your kind of
standard EVP
questions like you know what's your name
what are you doing here blah blah and
Sarah asks the ghost
um are you sorry for scaring me I'm like
I don't think that's a good question to
be asking but okay
now at this point Kyle I think Kyle or
the other guy or James the one of the uh
the audio visual guys he goes out to the
car like for more videotape or whatever
and he sees a weird guy outside like in
the side yard now initially he didn't
think that it was a ghost or nothing he
just thought it was like a vagrant or a
neighbor or something like that he just
said it was like this weird looking dude
kind of in the side of the house and
he's like and I called out to him like
hey what are you doing there and then he
followed him and he's like and then I
went around said there was like an alley
behind the house and it's like the dude
was gone and I couldn't figure out where
he had gone
now in the master bedroom
the EVP session continues uh with more
of your standard questions
and then while
um Regina and Sarah are sitting on the
bed they said they felt pressure on the
bed they said it felt like a toddler
climbing up on it that's what it felt
like and they both obviously like jump
right the [__] off like oh no
now Regina tells Sarah she's like well
if you're scared you can go and Regina's
like good because bye she just like
takes off and leaves Regina in there by
herself
at this point the clot I think it was
the closet door like the the door starts
rattling and then Regina goes over there
like she's gonna open it and then the
knob turns by itself and Regina probably
wisely is just kind of like nah I'm just
gonna leave that close and then she just
like leaves the room
so she leaves the room it goes back out
in the hall
and she's at the top of the stairs and
she sees a guy standing at the bottom of
the stairs and obviously like I said
it's not one of her team and nobody else
is supposed to be in the house and she
said that she also felt like the whole
time she was walking down the stairs
like after this guy like who like who
are you what are you doing here she said
she felt like someone's gonna push her
down the stairs the whole time
now she tells Kyle about it she's like I
just saw she's like it was a ghost it
was right there it was standing right
there and she described him and Kyle's
like holy [__] I saw a guy that looked
exactly like that outside just now and I
just thought it was like a bum or
something I didn't think it was like you
know what I mean well he said he said he
thought it was a big run or a neighbor
or something and um you know so they
said holy [__] like that was probably
like the same dude it was like a ghost
so James uh you know the the EVP and
photo guy he's he's very excited about
this he was very he's very young like at
least saw this show so he was like well
I'm gonna get a picture of this [__]
so apparently I don't know I wasn't real
clear about this but they said that he
kind of set up the camera like in a
mirror or something like that
and then he said that he when he took
the picture like he saw the dude for a
second like I guess in the camera
flashes I'm assuming what he's talking
about
um but he said he kind of felt it like
run behind him and he's like and you
could tell that the ghost was like not
happy about being photographed or about
them being there or whatever
so at this point the team has to leave
they've been there it looks like they've
been there all night because I think
they left like in the morning when
Mike was coming back from work so they
said well we need to go through all the
evidence we collected and we'll get back
to you in a couple days when we figure
out what's going on
now the picture that James took uh
supposedly had a clear ghost in it now
the one they showed on the show like I
said looks pretty impressive but I don't
know what the real one looked like
probably not that good because it looked
like you know a dude
um also when they listen back to all the
EVPs
um a lot of the EVPs will a lot of the
questions they ask like the ghost
apparently answered them
uh you know like Sarah asked are you
sorry for scaring me and of course the
ghost said no not like that and I was
like what a dick
also I think that at one point the ghost
said something like let me out
which I was just like we'll let you out
of where where are you but you know he
didn't answer that but that was another
thing that he said apparently
so yeah it was a little freaky
um so Mike is in his house and they've
actually sent over like the photos and
the audio and everything so he's in his
house in the haunted house like
listening to this [__] and so he's
listening to these EVPs gonna be like oh
no [__] this you know what I mean which
like you said you can't blame him
I don't know what to think of EVPs
people I don't either I've seen I've
seen paranormal phenomena there's no
reason to [__] do an EVP you just
hear a [__] voice out of nothing out
of nowhere objects being thrown they're
strong if you gotta get some kind of
sensitive equipment around to [__]
magnify the sound 5 000 times and [__]
to hear something to hear something that
would be any damn phenomenon there
I've really never heard any yeah I mean
other than maybe a couple that were kind
of creepy but the thing about it though
is that those would be like super easy
to fake yeah you know what I mean if you
were saying when you see when you see it
strong [__]
there's no denying it you're like you
can't believe it you're like [__] that
it's real
you know
like what they took what they told us
doesn't exist does exist damn what else
exists red was like if this exists does
that mean Bigfoot exists does that mean
UFOs exist
it causes you to reevaluate everything
yeah but see I think that
I don't know you can't be like that like
right across the board because then
you'd be like oh if this one thing
exists then everything else exists yeah
there's no Loch Ness monster that yeah
that that doesn't that doesn't make any
sense if there's something like a
Bigfoot it's not North America it's all
those are all like very discreet
categories of things
so I don't think just because one exists
that means they all exist
um so yeah so after so after we heard
these EVPs which were apparently really
freaky then he hears noises in the house
again
and apparently he said something shoved
him against the wall
like really really hard and I don't know
if this is because I don't think he said
this but on the reenactment they showed
that it was shoving against the wall so
hard that his feet like it put his feet
up off the floor you know what I mean so
I don't know if that really happened or
not but you know lifted him off the
ground
so after that happened uh he's just like
yep I'm out that's that's enough of that
so he just basically runs out of the
house and they said the only time that
he only time he came back after that was
to pack his [__] and get the [__] out
um because yeah his once the ghost
starts shoving you into wall that's
that's pretty much all through it I
imagine
uh he ends up getting a I guess his
company like he had put in a transfer
like to another city so he got a job in
another city and like rented an
apartment there now after he after
moving out he actually put the house up
for sale and they said it sold like
immediately like in three weeks or
something like that which is crazy
um but they didn't have any mention of
if the ghost bothered the new people
that moved into there or if it was just
a particular thing that happened to
him and his girlfriend or whatever but
that was pretty much so again I kind of
like these ones
I don't know why but I I guess I kind of
like the ones where they don't I don't
like the ones that just have that Pat
ending where it's just kind of like oh
we did an exorcism and it's like oh the
smell of sanctity you know what I mean
and it's just like we sorted it all out
with Jesus and all that that's I don't
like that that's stupid it's cheesy but
um I kind of like these ones where the
people were just gets bad and bad and
the psychic comes and it's like well
it's probably some haunting [__] but I
don't know if we can do anything about
it and then it gets really bad and
they're just like yep nope bye and then
they just leave
because that seems like that's more like
what would actually say what would
happen with us right we're just faded
away yeah yeah yeah and that's happened
on a couple shows too where it's just
like you know after a while like it just
got less and less yeah Fades away which
to me seems a lot more because I kind of
feel like the ones that are all like big
exorcism at the end I feel like there's
like an agenda there church gender
that's that's what I'm saying so it's
like I'm more inclined to believe the
ones where they just said yeah we just
couldn't take it anymore so we just left
um or ones where it just like gradually
got less until they there's a certainly
got a Paranormal Investigator that is
also a preacher
they sell books about what happened to
them in their haunted house yeah
but but you know so was uh the Warrens
were kind of like that right yeah they
were almost preacher adjacent
um not counting the teenage girl they
kept as a girlfriend and all that other
[__] that they do but you know it's just
kind of uh religious culty
yeah
no from what I've seen to the Paranormal
no religion is going to solve it
it's something outside your control it's
a paranormal phenomenon you've seen it
in the house back when it was turned the
TV on it open and [__] ringing doorbells
and throwing little objects here and
there could have religion had any play
in any of that no no that never even
crossed my mind to be honest with you
it would they wouldn't be there when the
phenomena was happening because it was
very intermittent and it was very brief
it's because I'm older when I was
younger I could and I didn't know I was
doing it when I was younger but when I
was younger I could really [__] make
a storm you know but you need a lot of
internal
conflict you know
and really had been going through a
divorce and I wasn't [__] happy and
it's just like uh
I was very disciplined growing up in a
military academy
and um there's no way to blow off any
steam except that
you know and it made an external enemy
that had the uh effect of binding the
family back together in the face of a
common foe but it didn't do anything
wrong really it didn't do anything I
wouldn't have done
just and it didn't really hurt anybody
no just kind of scare you or Entertain
You it did entertaining stuff too
and I'm sure it would give you any
narrative you wanted you know what I
mean like I didn't want to know what it
was said what was going to say
it was just gibberish
but it probably would have said
something eventually but it would be
saying something
the same things that a character out of
your dreams would have said because
there are characters in your dreams that
you can't control and they say and do
things that you wouldn't do
but they come from you they're they're
not an outside force and that's what
that's what a poltergeist is see I
always like that analogy because
everybody can relate to that everybody
has dreams where there's like all these
random [__] in there they're
doing things that you wouldn't and
they're doing things that you wouldn't
necessarily do and you're just like but
that's still you though I mean your
brain generated that so it's coming from
somewhere yeah
you know yeah well your conscious
self is only one part of a whole there's
all kinds of there's other versions of
you in there too and they're all talking
to each other rattling around yeah
there's you're a committee
pretty much yeah yeah and they've talked
about you and everything everything that
you've come up with that you think your
Consciousness invented no they did it as
a group they knew about it even before
you thought about it
your Consciousness is actually an
illusion that you're in charge you're
not making any of the decisions the
other ones are
well there's a specific part of your
brain that makes you feel like you're
just one yeah yeah identity right but
you're really not
you know which is why I'm not I you know
when we did the show about
um dissociative identity disorder like
about that that guy
um I'm I don't know if I'm entirely
skeptical of it because you know the
brain can do like some weird [__] and
like you said if you didn't have that
regulatory
part of your brain turned on that made
you feel like one cohesive person you'd
be a group then I can see how that might
happen like how you might have that
you'd be a group of perception and they
would all be in conflict with each other
trying to come to an agreement
because everything you're doing even
before you knew about it it's kind of
discussed
according to what I've read yeah and
what I've felt
well and even if you I mean even most
quote unquote normal people or you know
neurotypical people if you want to call
it that
um that have a sense of a continuing
single identity even the even those
people are often like conflicted you're
usually like conflicted like you can't
decide on some [__] it's like you know
part of me wants to do this and part of
me wants to do that you can't like
decide on [__] you know what I mean
there's a skinny puppy album called Mind
mind the Perpetual intercourse it's a
badass [__] industrial album but
that's always been a good description of
how I've my mind seems to be when I'm
relaxed it seems to be a conversation
between a couple people
and then you kind of like if you have to
do something then it becomes cohesive
and becomes you
yeah do you ever have that sensation
yeah yeah anything you think of there's
somebody else in there checking it and
responding to what you thought of and
it's kind of like you're honing on well
it's a constant back and forth and I
mean I thought most people had that I
mean maybe unless I'm crazy I feel like
I think most people are like that the
title of that album is mine which is a
possibility mind the Perpetual
intercourse mind the Perpetual
conversation that's that's what that
means it's just like yeah that's what
it's like
yeah I'm always feel I don't I I
wouldn't go so far as to say I feel like
more than one person but there's
definitely like conflicting points of
view in there that are constantly like
going back and forth they're almost like
different characters in there right
right right so I yeah I definitely do
feel like that yeah so that's I don't
think that's that unusual yeah some of
mine are kind of like Jack Torrance is
going ah other ones are like the Venom
going I made you what you are that kind
of [__] you know see mine aren't quite
that bad yeah some of them are right but
that's why I'm scared of the Poltergeist
because that [__] gets out of hand man
it hurts well see and then and yeah but
that you told me because I said yeah to
you I was like you know you might get
mad at me like Wing a brick in my head
one of these days it's more likely that
it hurts me
yeah but out of like self-hatred but
then you kind of but then you kind of
said oh you don't have anything to be
afraid of it was like I don't know I
kind of feel like I think it would
probably mostly attack me
for not living up to it or being a
failure that type of thing because uh
some of them in there are just real
caustic man
but they're they're aimed more at me
than anybody else
yeah I yeah I get it like I said I have
that same thing it's not self-criticism
it's not quite as bad as that um mine
aren't quite as harsh but they are
pretty harsh but not quite as one of
them is exactly like Venom yeah where
which is why you like that movie I love
that movie yeah that's it that's just
like I was like yeah yeah there's one of
them and there's basically I'm
protecting you you'd be nothing without
me you know what I mean you you're a
coward I'll just kind of it's it's like
that yeah but it's just one of the
facets in there that help inform things
yeah yeah and like I said I kind of feel
like most people have that where you
have these kind of conflicting
uh things that's like man I'm all right
I'm awesome stuff like that and you're
like no I suck yeah I mean it's like
that yeah it's like that like just
constant back and forth which you know
probably not entirely healthy but I do
kind of feel the Venom one is like pure
narcissism it's taking all the credit
yeah right yeah
holy [__] it's Mega it's it's a
megalomaniac and it's taking all the
credit for everything that I've done
yeah he basically says no I did it you
know it's like that I mean it is still
you technically yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
but yeah it's just one of the one of the
factions in there the one of the fastest
the brain is fascinating yeah I'm just
fascinated by that kind of stuff yeah so
if I wasn't so old I might go back to
like school and like be a [__]
neuroscientist I just like got so
fascinated by that kind of I'm so
fascinated by that kind of stuff just
because it's so weird and we don't like
understand
jack [__] about it really I mean even
after you know we understand a little
bit about it but not as much as we
probably should considering it's like
right there inside our heads and
everything
but uh but yeah so that was pretty much
the end of that episode no no big
exorcism no nothing like that you know
ghosts just like push him against the
wall and he's just like yep moved out
sold the house they never like I said I
liked that they didn't impose a
narrative on it they didn't try to
figure out who this little kid was who
the guy was that was walking around or
nothing they didn't come up with any
story like oh that he was molesting the
little boy and the boy loved cartoons or
you know what I mean they didn't like
come up with any kind of like [__]
story to go along with it they were just
kind of like we don't know who the
[__] goes are okay you just got
ghosts in your house and that's about
the end of the story so I like that
that's a so this is actually like a
really really good episode and I'm glad
that we finally got around to doing it
and I don't know why we didn't do it
earlier we gotta move on to New Seasons
now yeah because I think we've covered
pretty much everything from I think the
first four seasons I think we bought
them unless you want to re unless you
want to redo some like demon child or
something
we'll leave it on there we'll leave it
on the phone
we'll leave that one on the fans I mean
I tend to not want to redo things I know
we redid Haunting of Summer Wind but
bizarre the [__] classic episodes
they might need updates but we all
there's also a bunch of newer episodes
there's some that are only online that
we bought yeah
and like those probably be fun to talk
about yeah honestly because we could bag
all those yeah which sometimes makes for
a more fun show like these are fun too
but these are actually like good they're
good kind of creepy episodes they're not
like cheesy
not like not like that mummy one
yeah
was it AP is that the name of that guy
that got yeah what the [__] guys I don't
even remember now the one with the one
that looked like the alligator dog the
Nile is like a crocodile it is and not
it's like a Nile alligator God Egyptian
god I think it might his name might have
been apep
it's been a long time that's just that
whole episode that that dude was like I
mean fair play to him he was on there he
was trolling yeah he's [__] trolling
but he kept a straight face the whole
time yeah fair play
but yeah so I guess we're gonna wrap it
up so I can go take a shower and have a
snack and yeah then I gotta go to bed
soon but uh so get up early so um
Wednesday
is our next live stream obviously
and we're gonna do a cool show I was I'm
excited about what I've been wanting to
do this show for a long time but it
never wins in the poll but this time it
won God damn it we are doing the Mary
Celeste probably the OG yeah of ghost
[__] I thought we already did this one
no well we did a show about Ghost Ship
including like a long time ago but I
don't remember if we talked about the
Mary Celeste on there if we did then it
was like it would have been just like a
little bit because I remember we talked
about like the orang Medan which uh is
not a real ghost ship it was just like a
story that got conflated into a real
event
um but we talked about like the the
joyita or whatever we talked about but I
don't know if we did the Mary Celeste on
there I always thought that needed its
own show okay because
um because it's kind of like I said it's
sort of like the granddaddy of all ghost
ship cases and it's pretty creepy and to
be honest it's
um
I'm not really sure I know what happened
there I have a pretty good I mean I have
an idea what I think probably happened
but it's still pretty weird it had to do
with the cargo they were carrying if you
ask me yeah probably yeah
yeah so yeah so that's the show that
we'll be doing Wednesday night about the
Mary Celeste so I'm looking forward to
that hopefully you guys are too so
thanks for hanging out with us this
evening and we will see you guys again
on Wednesday night at 7 30 Eastern
Standard Time good night